[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today today's
question comes from Jackie in Utah
buckle up John my husband and I are 47
years old and we're both impulsive
Spenders hey I recently came across your
podcast hold on can we start right there
yeah that's some self-awareness I
respect
that
okay I just James I know we got to go
through this question but I just got to
startop right here we'll get there
eventually we are both impulsive
Spenders this is not a diagnostic label
like we are both
5'8 right just a fact so we can't reach
high things on our cabinets that would
be a logical sentence we are both
impulsive Spenders is not an empirical
fact the way this is laid out this is
actually my husband and I are 47 years
old and we both act like children there
it is we choose to be emotionally
immature with our spending habits and I
haven't read the rest of this I'm just
so sick of the way we have taken
adjectives and nouns and created them as
identity verbs like we've created them
I'm an impulsive spender hey what can
you do what can you do no you're an
impulsive child all right I will not
interrupt again unless I have to go
ahead thank you for that John that was a
very helpful
redefinition here we go I recently came
across your podcast and we both fired up
about getting out of debt I'm having
some real fear and doubt about myself
and whether if I'll be able to change my
habits and control my spending growing
up my family didn't have very much money
so I have always had a scarcity mindset
and I know that's where my impulse
spending comes from my husband isn't as
much of a spender as I am he came from a
financially stable home but they never
followed a budget the person I don't
trust to be able to make these Financial
changes is myself I've tried to change
in the past I get all fired up about
something and start down the road of
change but before long I revert back to
old habits I completely break trust with
myself and end up feeling ashamed and
defeated I desperately want to make
lasting changes with our finances but I
just don't have any faith in my ability
to do this how do I restore trust in
myself all right so first Jackie I
apologize for interrupting at the very
beginning and throwing a temper tantum
because you're calling it out I am
emotionally immature with my money and I
don't know what to do and I've got a lot
of compassion and sympathy for that
question so when somebody says how do I
restore trust in myself my instant
response is always be trustworthy be
trustworthy and so what does that mean
that means I have to begin to create a
world where
I do what I say I'm going to
do now sometimes we um Overlook uh we
step over dollars to pick up dimes when
it comes to stuff like this so for
instance I am a person who will always
follow the follow a budget how can I not
follow a budget if I spend money that's
not in the budget what do I have to have
to spend money I have to have my ATM
card I have to have cash cool if I take
away my ATM card if I take away cash if
I get rid of Amazon Prime then I cannot
do those things similar how can I stop
drinking Step One is get rid of the
alcohol get rid of the environments
where there's alcohol so how do I
restore trust in myself it's not this wh
Knuckle Event where you're going to be
flexing I'm going to put in significant
hurdles in my way that make it almost
impossible to fail when it comes to
gaining trust in myself like for me I
struggled with getting up and going out
to getting in the car letting the car
warm up driving across town to the gym
so seven or eight years ago I just
started slowly peace meal in the gym
together in my house now it's right
there right I've taken away all the
friction now when I say I'm going to
work out Tom tomorrow I just go
downstairs and work out see like see
what I'm saying so yeah Min and there's
been Seasons when I gave my wife my ATM
card I was out of control I was an
emotionally immature spender I gave my
wife my ATM card so I I literally
couldn't spend and then I had to sit
with that discomfort what do I want to
buy right now oh I don't really want to
buy anything I'm bored or I have a scary
meeting coming up or I don't really want
to go do this assignment or I have
administrative tasks I don't want to do
I had to deal with why I was feeling
those things I didn't have that
emotional that that little scrolling
thing that makes you feel so good that's
dope of me dope of me dope of me I
didn't have that anymore right so how do
you restore trust become trustworthy
what do you think George yeah I'm with
that I was just thinking there's this
element of kind of making the bad habits
more difficult and making the good
habits easy and part of that is I'm
taking the apps off my home screen and
putting just every dollar there so
anytime I open my phone I see every
dollar it's a reminder I'm G to put the
every dollar sticker on my debit card so
that I'm reminded to go check the app to
make sure I have the money and make sure
I budget for it it's things like that
they might sound silly it might seem
silly to other people but if it keeps
you on track if that calendar where you
have the red X because you did one more
day of budgeting and you tracked it
that's a win you don't want to break the
chain now that stuff matters
psychologically and so I don't know what
that is for our friend Jackie but she's
got to figure out the root of that and
where she's stumbling and if that is
Amazon we're taking out our debit card
information we are deleting it we are
making it difficult blocking that
website on our computer whatever we have
to do in order to get those good habits
in place I I can't stress that enough
that we over intellectualize Behavior
change sometimes and
um sit down with your husband and say
hey it's really really important to me
that every week we do a budget together
every Sunday night can we just put this
on the calendar that we don't ever miss
this this is so important to me it helps
me feel safe and I'm trying to change my
life I want to change our tree I want to
change everything about our world will
you just have this budget meeting with
me on Sundays right what husband's going
to say no to that and afterwards we get
to watch our favorite show and we can't
do that until we have the budget meeting
yes or if you want to be more
adventurous then watch a show but we
we'll get we'll do things together after
that right but it's it's about bringing
people together and good for you Jackie
good for you uh this kind of change is
hard but also wow and by the way
changing a scarcity mindset um begin to
begin to keep a gratitude Journal write
down five things a day that start with I
am grateful for and begin to tip well
scarcity mindset is cannot be in um in
the presence of that's right it it
Withers and dies on its own little
thorny vine when you are insanely
generous right um because then you
realize oh I gave this kid this guy I
over tipped this person because they
were so wonderful I gave them their
light bill or their water bill for the
month and that means I got to make lunch
for the next two days it's that exchange
is almost always worth it right always
always so good for you Jackie great
great question